bonsoir monsieur girard bonsoir alors
vous avez annoncé en marge de la
présentation du rapport pré électorale
que votre parti va promettre promet des
baisses d'impôts pour la campagne
électorale avec ce que dit madame
leclerc
avec la croissance qui ralentit avec
l'inflation qui rapporte beaucoup mais
qui va ralentir puis à toutes sortes de
pressions structurelles aussi sur notre
marché du travail est ce que c'est bien
raisonnable de promettre des baisses
d'impôts
d'une façon ordonnée et responsable oui
parce que c'est c'est l'argent des
québécois les québécois ont le fardeau
fiscal le plus élevé en amérique du nord
et nous on a toujours une somme 1 dès
2018 nous étions engagés à remettre de
l'argent aux contribuables
et tout cela doit être fait dans le
cadre d'une saine gestion des finances
publiques la priorité c'est bien
financer les principales missions de
l'état à long terme combien combien vont
coûter les baisses d'impôts vous
promettez aujourd'hui
en fait moi j'ai simplement donné une
indication
une indication que nous voulions
continuer à réduire le fardeau fiscal et
que c'était l'impôt sur le revenu des
particuliers que nous allions au sublime
et je n'ai pas quantifié le lin ce
n'était pas le but aujourd'hui c'est
parce que aujourd'hui on en aura pas pré
électoral avec les provisions par
exemple que vous avez décidé d'ajouter
dans le rapport pré électorale mais vous
nous parlez de baisses d'impôts un
milliard de milliards combien ça coûte
des baisses d'impôts nous aurons
l'occasion de présenter notre programme
en temps et lieu aujourd'hui ce qu'on a
c'est là où juste pour les québécois au
niveau de l'économie des finances
publiques on or un cadre financier qui
est prudent qui est responsable et
chaque partie pourra indiquer ses
priorités mais c'est certain que d'un
autre côté la saine gestion des finances
publiques est une priorité si on va en
récession saine gestion des finances
publiques si on va en récession monsieur
girard est ce que vous baissez quand
même les impôts mais c'est pour ça qu'il
faut le faire d'une façon ordonnée et
raisonnable ne faut pas se précipiter et
tout faire ça sans connaître la
situation dans laquelle nous allons
évoluer nous nous avons une prévision
qui a été vérifié qui est plausible par
la vérificatrice générale qui est en
ligne avec ce que les économistes du
secteur privé
prédisent alors ces 3 4% pour 2022 est
le scénario le plus probable c'est un
ralentissement modéré c'est à dire que
nous la prédiction pour 2023 c'est un
point 7% 3 allez vous attendre que
l'inflation se calment avant de baisser
les impôts pour ne pas justement adopté
des mesures qui seraient 10 qui
ajouterait des pressions inflationnistes
mais l'argument que vous donner c'est un
argument supplémentaire pour faire ça de
façon ordonnée parce que vous regardez
les horizons la première priorité c'est
financer les principales missions de
l'état sur l'ensemble du cadre financier
ensuite on doit revenir à l'équilibré
j'étais sur l'horizon cinq ans on a des
cibles de réduction de dette alors la
réduction du fardeau fiscal doit se
faire en cohérence avec tous ces
objectifs et c'est pour ça que ça doit
être fait de façon ordonnée je comprends
que
de façon ordonnée et je comprends que en
principe l'équilibré budgétaire 127 28
mai on a montré quand même clairement
qu'avant le fonds des générations ou en
enlevant vos provisions vous êtes déjà
l'équilibré budgétaire l'enlever
effectivement si il n'y a pas de
récession et que nous n'avons pas besoin
des provisions parce que les provisions
sont là aussi pour les risques moi et
mes et les risques économiques mais si
nous n'avons pas besoin des provisions
mais on ne nous sommes déjà avec les
budgets tu as une donnée importante mais
les données dans le domaine de
l'incertain le haut niveau pour les 18
prochains mois la probabilité d'une
récession c'est de l'ordre de 25 à 50%
selon les différents économistes pour ma
part j'ai donné la probabilité de 35%
est-ce que vous ne minimisez pas la
possibilité d'une récession qu'on ne
retrouve pas vraiment dans le rapport
pré électorale au contraire à la page 14
ont quantifié l'impact d'une récession
c'est-à-dire comprend les trois
récessions les plus récentes de
l'histoire du québec en moyenne une
baisse de 4 points et 3 % du pib qui a
coûté 8 points 5 milliards de revenus
alors tout ça est documenté on a aussi
utilisé de la révision de leur condition
10 milliards c'est ça la provision
serait suffisante pour couvrir la baisse
de revenus créativement est ce que
l'inflation est une manne pour le
gouvernement compte tenu des chiffres
qu'on voit présentement avec la
croissance qui est de 9 à 12% du produit
intérieur brut nominal avant qu'on
retire l'inflation est ce que
l'inflation est une manne pour les
coffres de l'état le stade hic le régime
fiscal est indexé alors ce qui s'est
passé c'est que cette année l'indexation
du régime fiscal s'est fait avant
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie et
donc le niveau d indexation du régime
fiscal et de deux points 7 % or
l'inflation est prévue à 6.5 pour ça
alors c'est ce différentiel là
effectivement amener des revenus
supplémentaires dans les coffres de
l'état quand on regarde les données sur
les sites intéressants dans le rapport
pré électorale parce qu'on va jusqu'en
2026 là et quand on regarde de toute
façon toutes les statistiques pour
l'avenir on voit que la croissance de la
population active est très lente on voit
que la croissance économique va être
plus lente qu'en ontario qu'en
colombie-britannique la moyenne
canadienne au cours des prochaines
années la croissance de l'emploi que
vous prévoyez dans les prochaines années
est assez faible également est ce qu'au
lieu de promettre des baisses d'impôts
comme d'autres partis le font d'ailleurs
en passant est ce que vous devriez pas
joué de prudence un peu plus davantage
compte tenu des pressions structurelles
sur l'économie du québec mais d'abord on
a un cadre financier qui est prudent on
aura des contributions au fonds des
générations qui atteint 5 milliards de
dollars 26 27 on a 10 milliards de
provisions on a prévu les coûts de
reconduction de programme on a prévu les
hausses de prestations de services les
coûts supplémentaires en infrastructures
alors un cas on a prévu le financement
des principales missions de l'état de
façon adéquate à long terme en lorraine
un cadre financier qui solide et prudent
maintenant vous parler de la performance
relative l'économie du québec la
performance relative du québec est
excellent nous avons réduit l'écart de
richesse avec notariaux de 3 % en quatre
ans et pour cette année 2022 alors qu'on
croyait que l'ontario allait faire mieux
que le québec en raison du rebond de
l'industrie automobile la plus récente
prévision de l'ontario ce du ministère
des finances de l'ontario 3.5 pourcent
notre prédiction pour le québec trois
points 4 % ok alors merci merci pour
cette entrevue pour le rapport également
bonne campagne merci monsieur girard
merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit